jason it's great to see you i see you
survived the pandemic very well we did
and are you still uh north of the border
i'm still in canada up in montreal how
do you like it uh you've been there for
five years now i think we moved from the
states uh four years ago in fact the
last time i was on the show i think we
talked about the economic benefits
of uh taking a u.s startup and running
operations out of out of another country
like canada uh
so i think to date now we're up to 1.5
million
of government support in canada for what
we're doing um that is unbelievable
yeah so every year you are able to take
your research projects and get a credit
you submit that to the government from
what i understand and then you wait and
see and then they will give you
reimburse
a reimbursement for a developer or three
exactly exactly and the motivation and
of course to qualify you have to have
canadian-based engineers to qualify
so most of the team now is in canada
[Music]
so we can get that grant money and you
were ahead of the curve uh you obviously
were in new york and uh raised money in
silicon valley got the best of both
worlds um but now everybody is remote
anyway so it doesn't matter um
so you were ahead of the curve on that
uh yeah now we're just caught up i'm
just like everyone else working from my
house
well is the panda i'm just as before we
get into the product is the what's the
state of the pandemic up there i know
canada was behind
uh was on serious lockdown and way
behind on vaccines what's the situation
been this past six months or so i think
now we would be uh around 10th in the
world uh of countries over a million
people to be fully vaccinated
i think above the age of 12
across the country we're like at 85 86
with two vaccinations
wow
extraordinary people believe in science
yeah the rates have come down
significantly here and where they do
exist it's it's like 6x unvaccinated
people the ratio to uh
vaccinated going into hospitals or
whatever yeah
yeah
i think makes sense
makes total sense here we got to in
california you know this high 60s low
70s depending on what region and we are
the i think
uh tip of the spear in terms of
compliance but yeah to get above 80 is
just so amazing and then we of course
have these pills you're going to be able
to take from pfizer these antivirals
should
hopefully end the pandemic if we don't
have another uh yeah major variant
in the meantime people play games on
their phones so we're pretty sure we're
pretty it's pretty great it's
interesting you say that
um it's always
to the audience you have to catch up
because we're all friends but um
it is interesting uh a lot of what i'm
seeing inside of companies is the
companies that were getting a massive
lift from the pandemic coinbase robin
hood doordash whatever now it's kind of
reversing and the go back to the real
world is starting to uh benefit a little
bit um
but yeah video games have obviously had
a huge bump so tell me about the new
product you created and
why you uh added this to the product
line obviously we've been covering nfts
and uh
had rohan from dapper labs on open seas
uh devon came on and of course we had
medicoven who bought people 69 million
nft so we've been all over this for the
past year
uh but nfts have been
you know mainly limited to
uh collectibles yeah and people have
talked a bit about games so here we are
you're uh jumping into games so tell us
what did you build and why
yeah so i think just to set the stage at
ready games we've been building tools
for creators to create game content for
the last four or five years and so our
core platform
was letting people create simple
hyper-casual games on mobile without
knowing how to code we have over two
million creators on that platform
and i'd say about a year ago
uh within the company we set to
ourselves
things are moving uh we need to be more
3d
more grounded around multiplayer social
gaming as opposed to solo and
we want to bring in uh the whole avatar
experience as the central unit of
creation
so
so what these are like principles that
we had and the reason we had those
principles is we felt that the shift in
gaming is increasingly just purely
social you know people are going into
games major ones like fortnite roblox
it's obvious that the loop there is
fundamentally a social loop
around the game experience and so what
we want to do is unblock creators to
build social gaming experiences on
mobile incredibly hard to do
because it's very expensive
computationally engineering-wise to
build
like true back-end services to allow
synchronous real-time gaming let alone
to do it in a low-code no code kind of
way
so so strategically we thought really
reinvesting deeply in our into our
intellectual technical intellectual
property was important
and it all had to work on mobile like
you had to be able to create this
content on mobile not on a desktop
there's 2.3 billion people on phones and
we're super excited about that audience
and super serving that audience so
over the course of the last year
we probably had 10 engineers working
full time really rebuilding out the
creative experience and it culminated in
two things one is called the ready games
network which is a platform that allows
independent developers to take a
casual mobile game usually a solo title
and turn it into a multiplayer social
game
and then in addition to that we created
an avatar system with all the cosmetics
that you can purchase around what's
called the metagame meaning the parts of
the game that don't affect the core
gameplay
and that is really hard to achieve on
mobile mostly very kind of advanced
companies have this type of stuff so
fortnite for instance has huge
industry around the metagame that's all
the skins and the stuff it doesn't give
you any advantage when you play fortnite
not gonna be better there's no pay to
win
but you look different and they do
hundreds of millions of dollars as you
know in sales on that stuff so we wanted
to bring that kind of capacity into like
picture a team two three people creating
a casual game
give it to them yeah so that's what we
did with icon that's what launched last
week icon is the authoring tool in the
ready games network that allows for the
creation of all the avatar cosmetics to
put it put the addressable market into
perspective it's a 40 billion dollar
spend this year just on cosmetics across
all gaming platforms 40 billion
uh buying digital goods and so
as we
on ramped like the the creator platform
for the avatar system the ability to
design clothing and shoes and scarves
and all the cosmetics that go around it
it was kind of a no-brainer to bind all
of that to nfts
and and and that's a deeper thing to
discuss but just high level
philosophically that's the jump that
lets you see this as an asset that you
can own as opposed to sort of
use as a consumable and from there you
know collect and use inside of
ultimately multiple games which we'll
get into how we support it across
metaverses across titles because that's
critical to the value yeah and here is
uh here's a quick video for those of you
watching on youtube we'll talk over it
and sportscast it
it's just a 24 second video but what are
we seeing here
well this is the internal avatar system
we designed a modular system where the
clothing can fit on all the points and
what you see here are the different
types of avatars you can create
and just
now we're in the app itself and you're
able to now customize that's a tailoring
event people are now tailoring the items
you can do all kinds of interesting
textures
and then you can bind it to nfts
and from there essentially have the the
rules set around
how
the product is sold you get five percent
of the sale
if you own the underlying nft in
addition to being the creator as the
creator you get even more on top of it
we'll get into that in more detail all
the economics but uh well we have a real
system everything yeah that that's the
really interesting part of this is if
they create their avatars here or if a
game creates the avatars
uh and i'm wearing that specific uh
you know clothing when i go to my next
game i could bring it with me if that
game were to shut down
you know fortnite shuts down or some you
know get there's a new version all all
of your skins don't come with you you
lose them or if you decide you're gonna
go from
minecraft to
roblox you're basically whatever you did
in minecraft is gone and you gotta start
over in roblox
when you are trying to grow a startup
fast hiring engineers will slow you down
like nothing else don't i know it so
many companies i invest in are telling
me they can't get their next version out
because they don't have a great engineer
well lemon.io will find you a perfect
candidate in just 48 hours it's a
marketplace of engineers from europe and
they test and interview every developer
to eliminate the risk of a failed
project lemon io is the perfect solution
if you are a technical co-founder and
you need to delegate some of your
important tasks or you have a project
that needs specific technology and you
don't have that skill on your team yet
or you are just growing so fast that you
need to add more developers and get more
done faster they'll match you with a
candidate within 48 hours and if it
doesn't work out they'll replace the
developer right away so here is your cta
the old call to action if you could use
a full-time or even part-time developer
to run your projects faster go to lemon
dot io slash twist once again lemon l e
m o n dot io slash twist and you'll
receive a 15 discount for the first four
weeks of work with that amazing
developer well done lemon okay check it
out everybody lemon dot iho slash twist